usé par le soleil recouverte de mousse
avec le temps les étiquettes botanique
sont devenus illisibles
comme dans cette collection remarquable
a créé en 1873 qui dit vieille
collection des vieux arbres mais dit
aussi vieille qui cache donc que cette
collection si environ 1600 arbres et
arbustes et à peu près 60% d'entre eux
ont une étiquette qui est soit présente
soit absente et quand elle est présente
et un état très avancé telle étiquette
qui ont 25 30 voire 40 ans d'existence
sur le tarn sur les 8600 arbres et
arbustes du site les deux tiers non plus
d'identité une information pourtant
essentielles ou dix sept mille visiteurs
chaque année
on n'est pas un parc classique ou une
forêt classique 1 c'est à dire qu'on a
plein de l'année différents donc quand
le public déambule dans l'arboretum il a
envie de savoir un petit peu là où il
est il passe de californie en amérique
du sud il repasse en asie et autres donc
avec le nom d' assurer que l'étiquette
qui a le nom l'origine géographique de
la plante ne permet de savoir où il en
est et puis pour nous gestionnaire ça
nous permet aussi de savoir où sont nos
plans tout simplement parce qu'on a pas
on a des plans à jour et autres mais les
personnels vont et viennent et donc un
besoin d'avoir une structure aussi sur
le terrain
le problème pour créer plus de 5000
étiquette c'est le coût 26 mille euros à
la charge du gestionnaire l'office
national des forêts pour la première
fois une campagne de financement en
ligne vient d'être lancé notre souhait
c'est vraiment aussi d'impliquer notre
public à la vie de l'arboretum
d'impliquer le public aussi à
l'environnement
on espère en effet que par cette
souscription on applique beaucoup plus
les gens quoi les dons débute à partir
de 5 euros
la souscription relayé sur le site
internet de l'arboretum se termine fin
octobre